on l'a oublié sur la côte normande
elle était pourtant une ancêtre de la
smn à l'usiné tréfimétaux de div
on fabriquait du cuivre ils étaient
encore plus de 900 à y travailler
quand elle ferma ses portes
définitivement il ya 30 ans tout juste
des années 80 les camarades
attendait mieux que ça 80 arrive marché
le programme commun on dit ça on va être
sauvée 90mn nationaliser 83 d'apprendre
la fermeture
je raconte paul comment comment ça s'est
passé dans nos têtes et 86 fermeture
finale c'était un choc terrible parce
que alors je demandais aussi qu'on
allait arriver à la fin du débat mais
par contre ce qui a été ressenti enfin
pour moi c'est que derrière il ya eu les
luttes qui ont redonné un coup de pouce
un petit peu à tout le monde même les
gens utiliseront des difficultés qui ont
dit regretter france bat ils se
retrouvent ainsi pour la première fois
des dizaines de familles se sont
inscrites pour une soirée d'hommage et
de souvenirs j'y suis entré
viens tu j'en suis sentie forcée
des souvenirs dont il essaie de garder
le meilleur puisque tu te rends bien une
bonne l'équipe une bonne heure blanche
et ont travaillé la fin d'une époque
la fin du travail on ne parlait pas
encore de mondialisation et de tyrannie
de la finance cela dit trente ans après
paradoxe vive la communiste a réussi sa
reconversion cité industrielle toujours
mais qui a aussi redécouvert la mer